Tens of millions of young Americans are drowning in student loan debt.
But one person is trying to reinvent higher ed...
...and the outrageous cost associated with getting a degree.
And he's an MIT dropout.
Our mission is to provide the most accessible, highest quality CS education...
...that is really out there in higher ed.
And a big part of that is not taking tuition from students up front,...
...and instead taking a percentage of their salaries.
'Cause there should not be a way for a school to succeed...
...other than producing successful students.
What really differentiates Make School from the traditional college?
Several factors.
There's no grades.
There's no tests.
There's no traditional problem-based homework.
It's all about building things as you would in the real world.
Do you think that students are taking too big of a risk to give up formal education?
I think culturally we've mixed up the cause and effect...
...between getting your degree and having a good life afterwards.
It's not the degree that got it for you.
It's what you will learn in the name of the school and the connections it brought you.